in our last episode we started looking
at best practices that you can use to
get the most value out of cloud logging
we covered how to ingest and store logs
how to centralize them and how to manage
log access and retention today we'll
wrap up this topic by looking at how you
can use advanced log queries to find the
exact logs you're looking for and how to
manage logging costs
welcome to engineering for reliability
with google cloud
let's start with using logs for
troubleshooting and debugging
i'm going to show you how to use
advanced queries to quickly find the
logs you're looking for and how to use
error reporting to automatically
identify classify and track application
crashes
an advanced log query is the boolean
expression that specifies a subset of
all the log entries in your project
you can use them to choose log entries
from specific logs or services specify
time ranges match specific metadata or
user defined fields and even sample logs
let's have a look
from the project dashboard let's go to
logging and select logs explorer
in previous episodes you've seen how to
use the logs field explorer to for
example select error logs being emitted
by our front-end service running on a gk
cluster
notice that our selections are actually
converted into a query
we can modify the query directly without
using field selections
for example we can negate one of our
expressions to look for all logs that
aren't errors
if we want to only get the logs for a
particular time interval we can easily
specify that using the timestamp field
we can even retrieve just a sample of
the logs by using the sample function
if this is a query we'll need later we
can save it
then access it whenever we need it in
the future from the save queries tab
so you can use advanced queries to
quickly and easily get the logs that you
want
saving your queries allows you to get
back to a set of logs you need to review
on a regular basis
advanced log queries are a great way to
quickly find the exact logs you're
looking for
but what if this was even easier
you may remember that we covered error
reporting back in episode 9. if you
haven't seen it no worries we'll link to
it in the episode notes below just
remember that it's an easy way to track
analyze and get alerted on errors in
your application
advanced log queries and error reporting
are really useful if you're trying to
understand the behavior of your services
being able to quickly find the logs
you're looking for and easily track
application crashes should definitely
help you keep your services healthy
finally let's get into managing logging
costs which is a key part of optimizing
your cloud spend
i want to show you how to view your
login usage how to track your login
costs over time and how to control the
logs that you ingest and store
first let's have a look at how to use
information in the cloud console to
understand how much of your bill is due
to logging and how much logging is being
ingested and stored in your project
from the billing homepage let's go to
report
here we can select our project and the
cloud logging service
this shows us the logging charges we've
incurred for the current month or for
another time interval
if we want to understand where these
costs are coming from
we can go to logging log storage
and look at the usage details for our
default bucket
this takes us to metrics explorer and
shows us the volume of logs ingested by
the various resources in our project
so that's how you can use the billing
report to stay on top of your login
costs and the utilization metrics to
track where the logs are actually coming
from
understanding your logging costs is key
to being able to manage them
but actually controlling those costs is
primarily accomplished by reducing the
amount of logs you ingest and store
we covered log retention in our last
episode remember that you are not
charged for storing logs for the default
retention period as such you can reduce
your log storage costs by carefully
considering whether you need to retain
logs in cloud logging for longer than a
default retention if you do need those
logs or other use cases consider
exporting them to google cloud storage
for archival or bigquery for analytics
your primary mechanism to reduce
ingestion costs are log exclusions
exclusions are configured when you set
up log syncs if you're looking to reduce
the volume of logs being ingested you
can modify the default sync to add an
exclusion filter
remember that excluded log entries won't
be available in the logs explorer or
cloud debugger
log entries that aren't routed to at
least one log bucket are also excluded
from error reporting
but user defined logs based metrics are
computed from log entries in both
included and excluded logs
of course the other way to reduce log
injection costs is to produce legs logs
from your applications
for example you can carefully adjust the
log levels to control log volume
this is especially useful for serverless
services where there's no way to view
excluded logs
consider both managing log volume in
your application and using exclusions to
balance observability and costs
thanks for joining me today we cover the
best practices for querying logs in
cloud logging and managing your login
costs i hope these recommendations help
you keep your services reliable and your
users happy thanks so much for watching
today don't forget to like and subscribe
to never miss out on more engineering
for reliability with google cloud see
you soon
you